i've built plenty of serverless web
applications that run in a single region
with a database in that region
but my new app is business critical so i
need high availability also my users
come from all over the world how do i
set that up vita
i'd be happy to show you
[Music]
if you're building an application that
has users from all over the world you
could put a single cloud run service and
a database instance in a single region
google will route the traffic and
everything will work
but what if my service or database goes
down or if google cloud has problems in
that region
then your application would have an
outage we can increase your app's
availability by making it multi-regional
all right i remember deploying my cloud
run service in multiple regions in
another video i shot with ahmed i'll
link to that video in the description
right if your cloud run service runs in
multiple regions problems in one region
are less likely to take down your app
but you will still have a single point
of failure oh what's that well if your
database runs in only one region and it
goes down your entire app goes down
okay so can i run my database in
multiple regions as well sure yes you
can um you set up a primary database
instance in one region and add a read
replica in a secondary region if
disaster strikes you perform a failover
and send all traffic to the secondary
region instead which then becomes your
new primary region
you would need to keep a close watch on
your database to make sure you detect a
failure and perform a successful
failover at the right time
and you only said that because there's
another way that involves less work
didn't you better
yes
i did
so if you pick a database that can
support multiple regions like cloud
spanner you gain three things
first you don't have to configure the
database instances yourself
set up replications between them and so
on
second your code can just call the
spanner api using the client library
and spanner will figure out which
database instance to connect to
and finally you can serve traffic from
all regions instead of just from your
primary region
got it i shot a video with derek about
spanner spanner is a relational database
right
that's right it uses the sql that you're
already familiar with it's strongly
consistent and it supports transactions
all right i have an app here which is a
simple rest api i've deployed the cloud
run service in multiple regions using
the instructions from that other video
now how do i set up the spanner database
in the cloud console click the hamburger
menu scroll down to databases and pick
spanner
enable the api and wait for it to take
effect when it's done click create new
instance and then compare region
configurations
okay
i see a drop down list here of regional
and multi-regional configurations
right so the regional configurations use
replicas in multiple zones within the
region that gives you a very reliable
database with a 99.99
availability surface level agreement or
four nines
now if you want to be sure that problems
in one region are unlikely to affect
your database pick one of the
multi-regional configurations using one
of those increases the availability
service level agreement to five nines
got it and my applications has users in
london and singapore now i don't see a
configuration with those two regions
specifically
okay so if you have users in london and
singapore pick a spanner configuration
that provides replicas as close as
possible to your users applications and
databases tend to talk a lot back and
forth before they return a response to
the user so deploy your cloud-run
services close to the spanner replicas
you may also want to consider cost and
carbon intensity when you pick your
region the data for that is all in the
cloud console
it says that the prices are for 1 000
processing units uh how does that work
1 000 processing units is the default
you can buy processing units in
increments of 100 if you only buy 100
the price will be 10 of the one you see
quoted there
if you buy 2 000 units the price will be
double the one you see there
and how many units should i pick beta
spanner allocates 4 terabytes of storage
for every 1000 processing units in other
words if your database is 400 gigabytes
or less you can get away with 100
processing units
also each 1000 processing units can
support up to 10 000 reads per second or
2 000 writes per second
many developers use 100 processing units
for their development and test
environments it saves money
for production environments it makes
sense to start with 1000 processing
units and adjust as needed the spanner
documentation goes into more details
about this
got it i will include the links to the
docs from the video description below
now what if i pick too many processing
units or too few can i change it later
sure you can you can change it even
while the database is running just go to
the spanner page in cloud console and
enter a new value or run the right
gcloud command from your command prompt
and do i need to update my application
code to hit the right span replica
no if you use the spanner client library
you just need to create a connection
send your sql query and spanner will
figure out where to run it also spanner
notices if any region or zone is down so
it won't send queries to it that means
you don't need to perform a failover
yourself
ah i love it less code is better
now all right pizza tell me if this
makes sense my development and test
environments will each be a single
spanner instance with 100 processing
units
each of them will be accessed by a cloud
run service in a single region
that sounds good you will save money by
only using 100 processing units
got it
my production environment will have a
multi-regional spanner configuration i
will set it up with 1000 processing
units at first and then adjust it up or
down as real traffic starts coming in
i will deploy a cloud run service in the
same region as each span of replica
that makes sense if you need four nines
of spanner availability go with one of
the regional configurations but if you
need five nines go with one of the
multi-regional ones which adds replicas
in more regions
that way you won't have a single point
of failure for your database
pick a configuration that includes
replicas close to your user
got it thanks for showing me this vita
and thank you everyone for watching
if you have any questions about
multi-regional clarion or spanner please
let us know in the comments
also tell us if there are other
serverless topics you'd like us to bring
up in future episodes
see you next time
[Music]